tant qu'on aille dans la voiture allait
son aura et moi on va voir ce que ça
donne en garde m on va l'avoir regardé
parce que je on a peut-être qu'elle
sauvera on va regarder la enora nabila
et nora reviennent on ira alors
attention et nora et l'habitat attention
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
transparent
oui je fais
[Applaudissements]
villasavary n'aura une habile à ses
nouveaux habits ils ont perdu vous voyez
ça va ça va ah ouais ça va trop trop
bien vous voulez leur faire rentrer
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
allah
merci bravo applaudissements pour la
guinée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout bon pour nous voir l'inde à ce camp
alors alessandra est ce que vous êtes
toujours chaude pour le faire partir ou
pas du tout en faire à très vite on vous
laissera prendre votre décision pendant
la chronique de camille combal vous êtes
la mairie des quads ce que vous voulez
moi jouer moi je décide ce que vous
voulez franchement s'il faut y aller on
ira bon ok mais on en fait pas beaucoup
mais je suis pas très manège là ça va
quand même assez vite d'accord on voit
on va le faire encore pour l'instant le
fait tout ce qui est d'accord mais alors
où il ya quand même nos lauriers
vraiment yacado l'ol ce que je raconte
tout téléspectateur il ya quand même
elle est la productrice de l'émission
delphine qui me dit que quand même
regarde si elle plus de boules à crozon
[Applaudissements]
ils soient fondantes je croirais regarde
quand même tiennent plus debout là les
kabyes combal et avec tous
[Applaudissements]
camille combal deux ans que cette petite
boule de talent map est en pleine gueule
by plus en plus bon soir bonsoir ça m'a
déchiré sandra alessandra laissant rien
à faire là bas je vous accompagner à
maintenant la salle et sandra qui va
conduire les gars molo molo molo il faut
absolument mettre la ceinture paraît-il
alors si je joue il faut juste avant m
peuple a trop vite
moi non je dois mourir tu n'aimes pas
les manèges ou des traitements a pas
trop me alexandra donne pas les villages
trop vite mais bon si j'aime pas les
maths je suis vraiment mais si si la
mairie ne l'est pas j ai couché ya huit
ans elle a accouché hier mois et demi il
y avait tout ce qu'il faut pas faire là
alors là ce avait avrillé sur l'abdomen
ça fait des gens coupés en deux après
l'accident le béa qui menace les 15
secondes ce qu'on doit rendre l'antenne
cabanac un second avec 30 secondes à 3
min ch din est alors s'il vous plaît
elle à l'accueil à la soupe est déchiré
et franchement pourquoi il a fait ça
depuis je sais pourquoi j'ai cette idée
des vies
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
oh la la
[Musique]